15 décembre 2020 la france où qu'ovide
démarre un nouveau cycle de restrictions
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans
l'actualité de ce mardi la fin de
quarante six jours de confinement et le
début dans moins de deux minutes du
couvre-feu qui va s'imposer à tous dans
le tarn à cagnac-les-mines le 15
décembre 2020 est aussi le jour où une
infirmière de 33 ans et vu pour la
dernière fois c'est le dernier jour de
delphine jubile arts avant sa
disparition
ce matin là delphine jubilaire se
réveille sur le canapé du séjour elle a
l'habitude de dormir ici surtout depuis
qu'elle a demandé le divorce il y a près
de six mois son mari cédric peintre
plaquiste est parti tôt en bus sur un
chantier elle est en vacances après
avoir déposé son fils aîné louis à
l'école primaire
elle part à albi à moins de 10
kilomètres de là avec sa fille de 18
mois pour récupérer des chèques cadeau
offert pour noël par le comité
d'entreprise de la clinique où elle
travaille
puis elle passe à la banque
delphine jubilaire de changer le code de
sa carte bancaire elle en a assez que
son mari souvent à sec retire de
l'argent sur son compte et au début du
mois cédric jubile arts s'en est servi
pour l'espionner en consultant ses
dépenses
delphine jubilaire a un amant que nous
appellerons gens avec qui elle souhaite
s'installer au plus vite et ce 15
décembre 2020 c'est le jour où tout
semble se concrétiser car la femme de
jean est enfant au courant de leur
liaison
à 13h08 cette femme envoie un texto à
delphine jubile arts puis un autre à
13h53 avant d'essayer de l'appeler
plusieurs fois
message demandé par jean nous nous
sommes mis d'accord tous les deux pour
que tant que nous habitons ensemble nous
soyons une famille j'accepterai tous ce
qui se passera après psychologiquement
je ne peux pas tout enduré d'un coup
laisse la place libérée avant de la
prendre
delphine jubile art appelle son amant
puis répond à 14h23 je serai disponible
pour te rencontrer quand les choses
seront posées en attendant je vais
m'effacer me faire discret tu te laisser
digérer la nouvelle et vous laisser en
famille selon son souhait
ce jour là entre 13h08 et 14h23 les deux
femmes échangent au total 25 sms et sel
une sorte de pacte delphine doit
attendre la séparation du couple au mois
de janvier pour poursuivre sa liaison
il est 16h30 après être ressorti pour
aller chercher son fils à l'école
delphine jubila retourne chez elle une
maison en chantier que cédric peine à
terminer un grand désordre à la limite
de l'insalubrité
selon les premières constatations des
gendarmes
vers 19h30 la famille s'installe pour
dîner cédric jubile arts à cuisiner des
pâtes avec des steaks et cordons bleus
pour delphine ce sera une brique de
soupe
ce mardi soir il y à la finale de la
france a un incroyable talent louis
s'installe avec sa mère devant la télé
le couple jubilaire en crise ne passe
pas vraiment de moments ensemble chacun
discute avec d'autres partenaires
delphine avec jean sur snap chatte et
cédric sur meetic avec des inconnus mais
à 22h08 le téléphone de cédric jubilaire
c'est un
faute de batterie ou volontairement en
tout cas c'est inhabituel selon des
expertises révélées par le parisien
cela n'est arrivé que deux fois en 2020
du côté de delphine le dernier message à
jean est envoyé à 22h55 à cette heure ci
il y as d'or depuis longtemps
cédric est déjà dans sa chambre et louis
part se coucher mais quelques minutes
plus tard une dispute éclate louis se
relève je suis arrivé jusqu'au couloir
et j'ai vu que papa et maman étaient en
train de s'attraper
aux alentours de 23 heures deux voisines
des jubilaires entendent des cris
glaçant des cris de peur des cris de
femme etait-ce delphine
le timing précis donné par les voisines
ne permet pas de l'affirmer
la suite c'est cédric jubilaire qui la
raconte il est 4 heures 10 quand il
appelle la gendarmerie d'albi
gendarmerie je vous écoute oui bonjour
je ne sais pas où est passée ma femme
[Musique]